hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report did you enjoy those summer
solutions
yeah i know i did well it's time to get
back into the problems
so let's turn to stacy right well
you know the fed had better hope the
solution
to inflation is just time because
remember they keep on saying
it is transitory well their
usual solution is giving more and more
money the treasury is always giving more
more money congress more and more money
so we're going to look at what some of
the results
that have come out while we've been gone
for the past two weeks
we've seen not only inflation numbers
hit over five percent
the highest in a very long time since
but container freight rate spike
to new extremes up
500 for asia u.s asia eu
since early 2020 and the worst is still
ahead and wolf richter
uses a quote from jerome powell just
under this it turns out it's a heck of a
lot easier to create demand
than it is to bring supply up to snuff
so uh we'll go over some of the details
on these rates but uh they're pretty
shocking max
right yeah that's a good comment by wolf
richter about demand
you know it's always spoken about in
keynesian
economics corners that they need to
stimulate demand
by printing money but we live in an age
now
where the supply side of the equation is
broken
so we're entering into these supply
shocks whether it could be microchips
for example
or basic commodities are up sharply
there's a food in security now
by hundreds of millions of people around
the world
just emerging over the past 12 months
because of this runaway inflation
because of the
runaway money printing as we've been
saying for a few years
so now people are really coming to grips
with the fact that
yup kaiser report's been right about it
what's next
right so we'll go over some of the data
the important one to look at the
in terms of the uh container freight
rates is from
shanghai to los angeles and so
think about this everybody got a lot of
stimulus checks we covered this
thousands and thousands of dollars over
the past
year a year and two months and what they
did
is they bought durable goods they bought
refrigerators they bought washing
machines
and where did it all come from it came
from china so
this is the most important one for this
kovid lockdown story and the supply
shortages
and rates spiking average port to port
spot rates
from shanghai to los angeles soared from
around 1
500 per 40-foot container in early 2020
and from a five-year average of 2177
to 4 thousand dollars in september of
to eight thousand dollars in june of
and 9631 in the week ending july 8th
according to drury
supply chain advisors this would be an
increase of over 500 percent
from early 2020. you see there's two
things i've been going on
for the last 20 years number one money
printing
number two china enters
global economy and all that money
printing
went over to china along with american
jobs but the american consumer didn't
notice that
because the price of stuff coming in
from china like those white goods
the washers the dryers the tv screens
the clothes
was dropping precipitously a lot cheaper
well at some point you know as you pour
water into a bucket at some point the
bucket is full and then the water starts
to spill over
so here we have a situation where all
the
cheap gains that have accrued due to
including china in to the world trade
organization under bill clinton
have exhausted themselves so all the
money printing like that water into the
bucket
is now spilling over as real inflation
but
i think the reason this has caught
people off guard is that it took 20
25 years to fill that bucket because
bringing china on as bill clinton did
was really a remarkable situation of
putting
half a billion workers making virtual
slave labor
into this globalized economy that was
all hooked up to the internet
and we just had an amazing crash
in the logistics prices and delivery
prices and
remember it was only two or three years
ago we were saying the price of these
containers
uh the baltic dry index if you recall on
this very show
two years ago three years ago we would
all say oh my god it's hitting new
crash lows it's so low it's so low
but now it's all been
essentially equalized or normalized so
the money printing is not going to hurt
really badly
the past 20 years why part of the reason
why i didn't catch up
was that there was a lot of money
printing but it was all credit
it came from the central bank cutting
rates ever lower
taking those assets off the balance
sheets of the banks and putting it on to
the central bank's balance
sheet the past year we've seen thousands
and thousands of dollars sent to every
single individual american
we saw those ppp forgivable loans tens
of billions of dollars given to small
businesses
this is real money it's filtered
straight into the economy
and without a commensurate of course
goods and services being provided here
so that's why you're starting to see the
inflation because
everybody's spending it but the only
place to spend it is in china
and the volume is uh quite remarkable
so what you see is the port of los
angeles has been setting records
in terms of the volume of imported
loaded
containers the container volume is
expressed in the
standard measuring unit of teu which
stands for 20-foot equivalent unit
where a 40-foot container contains two
to use
for the five months from january through
may the port
imported 2.37 million teu
and loaded containers according to data
from the port of los angeles
this was up from 26 from the prior
record
period of january through may of 2017.
so it's a
it set a new record high by 26 of the
previous record high you can see the
parabolic move
it all started exactly all of this data
started exactly once the first stimulus
checks
started to pour into american coffers so
it is causing uh some inflation is
causing some friction as well because of
course
you're starting to see um headlines
suggesting that it's china that's
causing inflation
or you see signs that it's bitcoin
causing hyperinflation right
interesting those two being brought up
in that context
look china's gdp is up like 18
and the us is barely positive
and big why because china is trying to
grow their economy
you know if you're trying to grow your
economy based on manufacturing stuff and
selling it
you're gonna end up with people working
manufacturing stuff
and selling it if you have an economy
based on social justice warriors who are
begging for more stimulus checks so they
can give it all to china
your gdp is not going to go up because
you're not manufacturing stuff to sell
to
chinese people or anywhere else in the
world well you're
definitely going to see i mean because
we haven't seen this in our entire adult
lifetimes
we had this in our childhood of the
inflation and it causes a lot of
friction it causes tension
because you have a you're flush with
money you're getting a lot of money put
in your bank account
you can't deny that there was tens of
thousands of dollars put into
average households uh you know savings
accounts and they're feeling good and
they want to go out and spend it
the problem is everybody else feels the
same and everybody else is doing the
same
and there's only so many goods and
services for people to buy
so you're also seeing that in the next
headline about how much
rent inflation is going up and rent is
an important component of
the cpi index right well rent prices are
soaring as americans
flock back to cities nationwide
rent prices are up seven and a half
percent so far
this year to date 2021 three times
higher than normal
according to data from apartments.com
analysts expect
rent prices to keep climbing for the
foreseeable future
a major burden for renters and a warning
sign that higher inflation could linger
far
longer than the white house and federal
reserve keep
predicting right you know the old uh p
and shell game you have a p and you have
three shells and you
you're like oh where's the p where's the
p
well the bureau of labor statistics in
washington dc have been playing this
game for
40 years 50 years where every year every
two years they
have a new definition of how to
calculate inflation
right they substitute hamburger for
stake they say a computer is twice as
fast so it's half as cheap
they substitute rent for houses
but eventually instead of having one p
to play with in the shell game
it's now three ps and every single shell
you turn over it's
inflation ah inflation and guess what
inflation so all those hedonic
adjustments
and all that gamesmanship has been going
on to help the
federal reserve keep rates low so that
the investment bankers and the private
equity firms have
cheapest possible money to buy other
companies for virtually nothing has come
to an abrupt
end in the form of people
starving so now the equation is really
cruel
because for every new billionaire you
can
make a direct link to x number of
starving people
full stop so yeah in the united states a
lot of people have
like i said over ten thousand dollars in
their savings account they haven't
spent it in the past year they're ready
to start spending it
they want it they're like hey i have ten
thousand that's enough for a deposit to
move to a new town to move to a new city
start again
um so flush with cash well everybody's
doing the same exact thing
and they're all heading to these cities
like boise idaho
they're heading to sacramento to other
like smaller cities not new york not san
francisco
and you're seeing the rents soar you're
seeing in phoenix
this headline here from this quote here
jason giroux
owner 410 real estate in phoenix said he
has managed rentals for nearly 15
years and never seen anything like this
his rental listings are often getting
more than a dozen
applications people call him and offer
to pay more
than the asking price for the rental
effectively creating bidding wars on
rental properties
on two recent listings so many people
offered to pay more money
that he had all the applicants write
down their best offer
right notice it's about renting and not
buying
because one of the fallouts from the
cobot crisis
has been the private equity groups like
warren buffett and others
buying thousands and hundreds of
thousands of properties
and putting them out of reach for buyers
and now
their only recourse is to rent and now
we're seeing rents rise
but of course they can't afford to buy
houses anymore so you end up with
essentially what would become
a hut on the company store
on the consumer plantation
known as america right well you're going
to be talking to rick ackerman who
believes deflation is the biggest story
but that's i don't think it's a
consolation at the end of the day
it's like you could say hey you know the
good news is there's
5 trillion or quadrillion in bad debts
over here
and that's deflationary it's going to
cause a economic crisis
but your rent is still going up your
health care is still going up freight
costs are still going up your
all your goods and services are going up
in price at the end of the day
i really want to know what rick ackerman
has to say about all this don't go away
much more coming your way
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to return to the
legendary
rick ackerman of rick's picks
rick welcome back thanks much for
inviting me on max
i'm looking at today's new york post and
the front page
huge headline the incredible shrinking
dollar
it's talking about inflation it's
talking about prices
skyrocketing so let's talk about this
inflation
versus deflation debate
yet again first of all why do so many
people
don't seem to understand these two words
inflation versus deflation
why is there such confusion is it
obfuscation for a purpose
or are people just mass massively
ignorant on the topic why do we always
have trouble with these two words
i think because you symptomatically have
both things going on at the same time
sometimes but also you know the
monetarists sort of set the
agenda for inflation they said that uh
inflation was simply an increase in the
supply of money
but i would submit that there are so
many fungible forms of money anymore
that you really can't measure it you
know i
i always suggest that you look at
inflation
or deflation in terms of the chief
symptom which is
for deflation it's an increase in the
real burden of debt
uh meaning that whatever you owe is
going to be paid back in
dollars that are increasingly dear and
of course inflation
uh is an opportunity for borrowers to
pay back what they owe
in cheap in dollars so i think if you
want to understand inflation deflation
just ask yourself for one what's what
has my mortgage burden gotten harder or
lighter
okay so you're saying a couple things
there first of all
the uh just the supply of money is not
necessarily a good gauge
when you were talking about inflation
because there are so many different
types of money now
uh it's that it's impossible to totally
get a handle on this
and uh one one index that seems to be
really the telltale index would be the
dollar so the dollar is showing a lot of
strength recently
and so that plays into this deflation
theme
and um but nevertheless
you've got uh cpi at 5.4 percent
rents up 7.5 freight container rates are
up 500 percent
and um to get back to what you were
saying there you got two things going on
at the same time
you've got destruction in the capital
markets or destruction in the bond
markets that's deflation
but you've got all this money supply
what about the average person out there
i mean the average person
they're experiencing inflation so why so
isn't that shouldn't that be the primary
thing people are talking about or
what am i missing well let me mention
one thing you know as far as destruction
of the capital markets it's inflation
that does that
deflation more or less leaves the system
itself
intact because essentially the borrowers
haven't been screwed the
deflation visits pain on borrowers
uh the lenders haven't gotten screwed uh
as far as what's going on now
you know you can see that that conflict
between inflationary forces and
deflationary
let's just take the renters that you
mentioned for one you know they've all
been subsidized for quite a while
uh it works out to be sort of a transfer
payment to landlords that they've
received from the government
but we're running up against i think
it's a july 31st threshold on
uh the non-eviction clause in
in one of the stimulus bills and if
all of the let's just take the extreme
example
where these checks that have subsidized
rents for so long stop
flowing so that's going to put a squeeze
on the landlords they have their own
borrowing their own mortgages to pay and
that's really deflationary there's no
question though that if you go out
shopping pretty much everything is
that the prices are insane but uh you
know we
we've uh never really made a distinction
between
whatever kind of inflation we're
happening we're having now
and the one in the 70s it was driven by
a wage spiral but right now
we have inflation driven by um an
asset explosion and uh that's why
they're very different you know the the
70s inflation
was uh let's call it organic it had a
push and pull
factor and and wages push prices up
which in turn push wages up but now most
of the inflation doesn't come from that
kind of slow acting
dynamic it's really coming from an asset
inflation
that could collapse any time you know if
you have a
bear market in stocks you're going to be
deflating like crazy
to follow up on a point that you just
made and one that
a mistake that i make often
so in other words destruction of capital
is really associated with
inflation because you're increa
increasing all this money and you're
destroying the purchasing power etc
where as deflation as you're pointing
out here
is an attempt to preserve the system as
it is
and so this is why when banks
are about to default on their debts the
federal government just comes in
and does some quantitative easing they
take all that bad debt off their balance
sheets and they replace it with some new
fresh treasury bills so they're not
they're not allowing the system to
cleanse itself
of all the mal investments that may or
may not have occurred
they're keeping a system afloat that is
um not worthy to be kept afloat because
of all of the terrible price signals
that are going on
um therefore my conclusion is
that the deflation
or preservation of the system as we're
seeing it now
that that's a political act right so
there's a political dimension
to this economic problem it's not
it's not capitalism it's not it's not a
it's a political problem is that a fair
statement well it is uh
it's not even really much of a decision
you know we're really
at the point of inflate or die right now
and
uh it's we've been sort of fending off
deflation for two decades
um and
we're not sort of standing still in that
process you know the more
uh the whenever you uh defend
inflation whenever you try to hold the
line against
that deflationary juggernaut that's
waiting to implode
you're essentially using borrowing as
the mechanism
and so we've had a lot of money barred
into the system
at a given fixed interest rate and i
mean fixed in in a couple ways
or mainly in the way that gamblers fix
horse races
so we really can't afford to have
interest rates
uptick because it will subject literally
quadrillions of dollars of borrowing
that have been lev
that have been done uh on planet earth a
lot of it through the derivatives market
uh to a somewhat higher rate of interest
and
that that would be crushing but i think
the effort
is doomed to fail simply because
the the key here is the real rate of
interest and when i mentioned that the
burden on debtors earlier
that's what i meant to imply uh in in
and eight when the housing market
collapsed people who had
what were historically low mortgages
were
were crushed really because the the
value of the underlying asset was
shrinking
so if we're at we've got interest rates
jerry rigged down to one or two percent
that can still become a crushing burden
if the collateral that's behind it is
shrinking in value
let's look at the 10-year treasury for a
second it's
at 1.4 percent inflation is running
at a stated rate of 5.4 percent
so um you know how much
longer are folks willing to hold these
treasury bonds
i mean you know that seems to be the
linchpin of the whole system
if there's still support in the treasury
market they can keep this thing going
but how much longer is that going to
last you think
rick from a technical standpoint if you
look at the very long-term
chart of the 10-year and the 30-year
we're really in
a corrective phase it feels like a bear
market where
interest rates are going higher and bond
prices are going lower
but to the extent that we've had that
for a while
it looks corrective to me on the other
hand i don't think that
you know the the current uh interest
rates are coming down i think they have
a little further to go but i do feel
that there's going to be an upward skew
in interest rates before
the larger that you know long-term trend
going back 40 years in the bonds
reasserts itself with by way of higher
bond prices and lower yields
so we've got a little bit left on the
bond rally i guess the 10 year
could flirt with 1
um i guess and then that 40-year bull
market in the bonds
you think and you're essentially a
a timer you know you're a guy who makes
his bones by
reading charts and you have an excellent
service over there at rick's picks has
an excellent track record
you think that we're approaching the end
of this bond 40-year bond move
rally rick i think it's got some room
to the bonds have room to rally meaning
rates can go lower
but obviously the big uh you know the
big play
the thing that made uh a portfolio that
just stuck with bonds a huge winner
was that that that move is is over you
know you're really
sort of squeezing out the last little
piece of it which would take rates down
from uh from two percent to well
lower and um for a while everybody
everybody was talking about negative u.s
rates
i don't really see that happening under
any circumstances
but it's really mainly because
the collapse is going to be is going to
happen
when you measure the real rate of
interest so we could have interest rates
as i mentioned earlier down near
two or one percent and it would still be
a crushing burden because the borrowing
that took place
um the the value of the collateral would
be falling we have now a situation
around the world
where uh the inflation's causing a lot
of food insecurity
uh millions of people are now similar to
when we had the arab spring and we had
the financial crisis
we had the food insecurity issues
contributed to revolutions and uprisings
we're on the cusp of that seemingly
would that have a feedback
into the markets would the markets look
at that and have any kind of impact at
all or would they just continue
with the status quo right well i think
the the
big enchilada really is the energy
market
you know coming out of the 2007-8 great
financial crash
uh the the smart guys looked around and
think well what can we hock up to our
eyeballs
and since uh housing was a non-starter
at that point
real estate they decided well let's hock
the oil packs
so they did and miraculously you see the
price of crude rallying now into the mid
70s
and there's no way that that's that's
driven by demand it's almost
like the stock market you get a little
incremental
feeding into a market like amc
or gamestop and it's you have a kind of
short squeeze effect
so i'm not quite sure how that would be
engineered and crude
but it's sort of a for it's a benign
miracle that crude prices are so
high because that's really where a lot
of the leveraging took place you know
the
global markets have been uh pledged
against oil
and energy assets to an extent where uh
you might say we we
really need for these prices to be high
but i don't see the support of demand
there
even from the biggest user at the margin
china all right
rick ackerman thanks so much for being
on kaiser report thank you max for
inviting me on
that's going to do it for this edition
of kaiser report with me max keiser and
stacey herbert want to thank our guest
rick ackerman of
rick's picks until next time bye y'all
[Music]